that's ten stone in the rotunda of the
Capitol are the words here serve the
people government those words were
spoken by Alexander Hamilton when he
asked what Congress represented to the
framers of the Constitution the Congress
was the first branch of government the
place where the people's representatives
met to decide the people's business yet
when the Constitution was unveiled many
leading Americans were outraged one of
them was Richard Henry Lee of Virginia
who had been president of the
Continental Congress during the
Revolutionary War Richard Henry Lee said
this Constitution has very little
democracy in it what he was objecting to
was the fact that the people were not
allowed to vote for the President or for
members of the Senate only the House of
Representatives would be chosen by vote
of the people
when Henry Clay of Kentucky one of the
great legislators of the 19th century
left the Senate to run for the House he
said I prefer to serve in the people's
chamber some critics today wonder
whether that label still applies to the
house they point to House elections
which have become increasingly expensive
it was not that long ago that these were
relatively modest Affairs funded largely
by donations from people living in the
district today it's easily the case that
a house election can cost a million
dollars or more with much of that money
coming from wealthy individuals and
groups from outside the district critics
also point to redistricting the tendency
of state legislatures to pack house
districts with voters from a particular
party thereby guaranteeing the election
of that party's candidate in the fall so
who's doing the electing is it the
voters or is it the state legislatures
and the wealthy donors those kinds of
issues about self-government have been
part of the American debate since the
writing of the Constitution